[Music]
that was the most amazing thing thank
you I love you both so much you know
that Ashton Kutcher just pulled off one
epic surprise for his friend and
neighbor Ellen DeGeneres the 40 year old
actor and his business partner Kyle Siri
stopped by Ellen Show on Wednesday to
make a giant donation to the Ellen
DeGeneres wildlife fund with a little
help from the app Ripple whether it's in
New Orleans whether it's in Montecito
whether it's the people that come here
the people out there you're always
thinking about everyone else and we
wanted to show you that people are
thinking about you a multi-million
dollar donation we'd like to give you
four million dollars Ellen's namesake
gorilla Conservation Center in Rwanda
was gifted to our back in February this
gift had to be really special can it hat
to represent who you are and what you
really care about when the talk show
hosts wife Portia de Rossi surprised her
for her 60th birthday when we got
married
horses line was it's good to be loved
it's profound to be understood and she
understands me because that is the best
gift that anybody could have given me
[Music]